I think we're just beginning to realize
the power of technology in education
actually and isn't it interesting that
education sort of the last profession
that technology has transformed and I
think a lot of that is because we can't
just plop down you know new tools into
an old system and expect that to work so
a lot of where we're seeing the internet
be the most powerful is in these blended
school models where schools are starting
to flip their classrooms and use the
internet and technology-enabled tools
whether that's videos of experts talking
to students or whether it's students
getting online and doing assignments in
a collaborative way answering a really
powerful and critical question that
their teachers might assign or whether
it's back and forth feedback between
kids and teachers and this blend of both
face-to-face with teachers and
technology seems to be a really powerful
both motivator for kids but also you
know the beginning numbers say it gets
incredible impact particularly for
students who may have been before
lagging behind so those collaborative
ways to bring kids into ownership of
their own learning and to use those
tools in ways that kids live and work
today are very powerful but it's also
proving to be really powerful for
teachers so that teachers are also
getting online and collaborating with
each other and using a number of social
networks they're also coming together
and co designing tools that will help
them be successful and sharing things
that they found that are really
effective practice and uploading you
know videos and looking at their own
practice and having others critique it
and critiquing each other so all of
those things are just now beginning to
take root and and materialize in schools
and I think you know some places are
further ahead I think what's exciting is
in three or four years we're going to
look back and be amazed at how much that
has exploded and how much teachers have
actually driven and students that
conversation but it's also true that
there's big challenges right
connectivity is a big challenge actually
having the tool the hardware tools the
platforms to work for
remains a big challenge and in education
you know not a lot of innovators and
entrepreneurs I'm going to step in and
develop those things because we had 50
different states with 50 different
standards and different procurement
systems and it just made it hard and I
think there are things happening now
like the Common Core State Standards
like this demand on the part of both
teachers and students for content
delivered in more creative ways to them
for both of their learning that you're
starting to see that change because
demand is starting to meet up with you
know sort of those people who'd like to
really tackle that in in ways that we
have an experienced before what we see
happening across the country that we
think is actually more of the wave and
more powerful is this blended learning
environment in which kids and teachers
together use technology enabled tools
that make the learning more real-time
more powerful give them access to things
they wouldn't have had access to before
and so we really believe that's the wave
of the future so I think we want to keep
thinking about the fact that kids really
need that opportunity to collaborate
with their peers and they're still going
to need the facilitation and guidance of
great teachers and so how do you make
all those things come together in a
really magical powerful way
you